what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yep
yay guess what
everybody what it's a sister episode no
you ruined it i wanted to say that okay
you could say it what were you going to
say it now it's a system
[Laughter]
i had to take the limelight before you
would come in
always does that to me i'll set it up
i'll tell her i'm going to do it and
then she's just like
so that's story i what when cece sets up
the story she'll bring in like the whole
ambiance she'll tell it
he killed her at the end like super
awesome
anyway hello everybody welcome back to
another episode of
unwaxed we're glad you're here and if
you're just joining us welcome
we are i think we've been looking
forward to this episode
for so long yeah i don't know why i'm
happier now
like jittery guys do you see my hands
it's not shaky but [ __ ]
no so it's really good i feel like we
have a lot to update you guys on and
i think for the first time you can kind
of just see our personalities a bit more
not
interviewing anyone and yeah i think a
lot of people already asked us too
when we would do a sister episode and
that was also with scarlet or without
scarlet but
which we will bring our little sister on
yes very soon but this is going to be
very interesting because
i don't think we have really one topic
we're going to just go off on and
we have a lot of things we want to bring
up so i want to jump
right in last week's episode i told you
guys that i went
on a first date with a guy no there was
none of that
there was none of that but it was really
good therefore
date number two commencing tonight and
what are you guys doing tonight i think
we're getting sushi
so it's really funny because i love the
valley
i love the 818 we went to high school
around there
we know the area i love it but a lot of
people don't like the valley because
they just think it's a gross but i think
it adds character
so as a joke i was saying you know
we got to go to the valley it'll gross
you out in one street you can get
pizza and hookah and like a lobster bar
all in one place like it's incredible
that's very true yeah where else can you
do the ango mini golfing like it's just
i mean it has everything and it takes
like two minutes to get anywhere
so it's great i didn't realize that he
was like serious i was joking and he
goes well i made us a reservation for
sushi in the valley which i'm like okay
we're going to need to bring tums
because you will get a stomachache
fellas fellas take note on that if a
girl
has been hyping up an area or it thinks
there's a funny inside joke
listen to that move i like that move
that he did now that he's going for i
remember when you came up to me and you
mentioned like we're gonna go to the
valley all this stuff
it was a i was pretty impressed by that
yeah i mean because you said that you
brought that up that night
check check mark but you you like this
guy i mean you came into my room talked
about him you're like no no no
i'm still stone cold i'm just kidding
steve austin
no but he is a good personality do you
are you fight like feeling good
what's what's like a what does he do
that like probably makes you
feel better about like other dates
you've had um i think he's really funny
and he initiates a lot of the
conversation which is nice so i don't
have to work so hard to impress him
i feel like a lot of times when i go out
with guys i'm trying to sell myself on
them as if it's like an interview
which is which is oh because it's just
getting to know each other exactly but
it's good and
um i was actually talking about this
with my mom
not that long ago um and we always
question like
what's the right thing to order when
you're on a date
you know what from a female's
perspective that's so true i mean
there's so many little things that you
can say like oh pesto gets in your teeth
or you don't want to eat like
fish because it's you smell bad i don't
think i mean maybe it's just us
but we order very strategically yeah
because
we want the burger or like because then
we'll come off as
the really cool chick that has a burger
with the beer i hate to admit it i
literally will prepare all day just so i
can order
some nice so you can be that girl yeah
but then if you order the salad
are you looked do you look like you're
uptight and you don't want to like
order something fun and different
exactly
i thought about it a little bit more and
i'm like huh guys probably don't even
give a [ __ ]
nor notice what you want what you order
or yeah so i just thought that was funny
but
i actually asked my doctor about it too
just because we have a good friendship
and he said that um men
science and studies show that men prefer
women that are meat eaters
maybe just because it goes back to the
time when everyone was a carnivore
like when everyone was cavemen right and
i'm not really sure i don't believe
that's true especially in l.a i think
men probably like vegans now because
that's just like the thing
and i mean you know it also shows that
maybe guys like that she's open to
trying
other things because stereotypically
girls will probably go for like the
salads and the clean things
maybe that's an l.a thing more yeah so
but when you can show a guy like what i
remember when i would order like a pasta
at dinner i was like yeah i like that
order and it will share
food is really interesting with oh yeah
i can explain what i do it's really
strange um if you tell me the
reservation and the place we're going to
i will look it up on yelp and i'll look
at the menu check out
what i'm probably going to order okay
already decide eight hours ahead of time
let me just reiterate sophia will look
up the menu
pick out her meal for the dinner and
then
act as if she's like what's good here i
thought you're not crazy
the chicken parm i think i'm gonna get
that like
oh that is cooked really well it has
glazed onions and some pickles
nice see is that but is that i'm asking
the people
and maybe you too is that too extensive
or are we well i don't tell the guys
that
obviously but are we just overthinkers
like they really just don't care
i don't know but i did read that if
women like research shows that women eat
spicier food
that they find the man more attractive
than sweet food or like savory food
what isn't that weird wait so if women
eat spicy food yeah i said that if women
eat spicier food
they're gonna more likely find that man
attractive if she's eating something
spicy is it because like her
vision might get blurry yeah she can't
she's distracted by the spice in her
mouth to see that
this guy probably sucks in front of her
um but yeah i do look up the menu before
and i feel like guys really
probably don't care yeah but guys do
other things that are cringy that they
won't admit to
right so let this be ours but you
actually were telling me a while ago
you were very excited about this study
that you found going off of
yeah like what men find attractive well
i
i love researching what the science
behind biology and
um attractiveness between men and women
because i think that
there's a lot of things that we give we
had a conversation about this the other
day that
when our odor is a certain way or like i
know it says like pheromones or
whatever it was that men will find you
more attractive even if you look
like crap like they still give you more
attention so i was doing a little bit
more research and i found like quick
things that men find attractive enemies
i'll tell you so men love youth in women
just because of fertility
and i mean it's it's like c'est la vie
and then that's also goes along with red
lips that's also another
red lipsticks yeah that's why a lot of
women will wear on a first date
red or black because red especially on
their lips just looks a little bit more
sensual and useful i'm taking notes for
today
this is kind of random but it was this
uh it was this cognitive psychologist
named
i think donald or darren howard i forgot
what his name hoffman something hoffman
okay and he said that the width of your
iris is another thing that
men what because it's another sign of
fertility because i think as you get
older that's some men just like women
that look fertile
yes and symmetry well
i have like one side of my face going on
yeah so he and i actually do have like a
paralyzed mouth
notice how we're sitting on this side
you'll never see us from the left side
and by the way
thank you lord for giving us our sides
of our face like we could stand next to
each other and it's our both of our
favorite sides
um but women's so bad women
like a man's odor print what does that
mean
odor print so it's a the musk that's why
when men work out
sometimes women don't find that as i
mean unless they're really small i
know what you're saying there's my
girlfriends are like i love
the smell of my boyfriend when he just
finished a workout and he's sweaty i'm
like
that sounds like my worst nightmare
they're like no the natural pheromones
it's like a sexual
if you're not initially sexually
attracted to his pheromones like you
guys won't be compatible
see like they don't mind the smell of
his feet or his fart i'm like whoa
what yeah no no i remember times where
i've been on dates guys like oh you
smell really good i'll i probably have
forgotten
perfume and then some guys are not like
that it really just depends and it's so
you can't it's so on it's on my
conscious i don't yeah yeah you don't
see my pheromones i feel like are
clogged
because i am wearing seven layers of
fake tan
so i do smell like so you smell like bo
well i would like to say
b.o like masked in a lot of perfume
but still the original oh god and then
two other things were deep voices for
men and
men with beards or scruff they said that
men that are clean-shaven
are seen as short-term relationships and
men with
longer beards and scruff are seen as
long-term relationships
do you i know you know what i'm thinking
about all of these and i want to know
exactly like when the study was done how
many participants were involved in the
study
i want to you know check me yeah i want
to bring someone on because i feel like
um what was attractive to the male eye
in the 70s 80s is completely different
from today but you know what also kind
of freaks me out
is about online dating is that all of
this stuff really isn't important
because you can edit everything online
so we also can make this fake beauty for
ourselves so you can make yeah you can
make the irises wider you can make your
lips
redder you can make yourself tanner but
they can't smell you
they can't see really your real symmetry
do you think that's why on the snapchat
filters you know every time you go on a
filter it's like your eyes get bigger
and your lips get bigger and your face
gets slimmer
yep that's what i'm saying it's natural
what's going on but i think they also
said that that's not something we need
to worry about until like
way later when uh technology is becoming
extremely relevant and because society
hasn't changed
as a whole for like hundreds of years so
we'll
that's when we adapt but at the meantime
we're here the conclusion of this topic
was i'm going to be wearing red lips
black clothing um i'm going to
eat spicy pheromones so maybe work out
show up sweaty ew okay
so okay can we just talk about the fact
that um we are getting another
dog yes we go
look at will's face so my another one my
mom
is a cavapoo fanatic
fanatic i would say she's a cava
a connoisseur in cavapoos if you will
she's obsessed
with these dogs you guys they are called
our sisters
they're not called our pets they're our
sisters and we kind of figured out
where this is sort of coming from
because she came in the room the other
day and she goes
girls i got another one and we're like
no mom there's really
even no more room for another dog
and we have two by the way yeah so we
realized sophia is moving out soon
you're i'm probably gonna go with you
she wasn't planning my younger sister is
18 headed to college soon
yeah so is each of these dogs us and we
are getting replaced by
cava poos we are yeah by the way the
personality of the dogs
are our personalities because winnie the
oldest one
is super soulful like attachment like
loves
love whatever yeah she billy is like
though
she loves attention but she's way more
confident i'll tell you how the family
describes billy
um psychology is the stupid one
but she's creative is that supposed to
be me
she's like she's artistic psycho and
then um
we have i guess apparently he's a boy
it's a boy which is cute you guys we'll
bring him in if you guys watch these
videos
so then you can see him he's really cute
really
i'm excited but he is i we're being
replaced
so we're going to take a quick break but
before we go i would like to uh sort of
set up
the special guest that we have on i know
we opened up the show and said you know
it's a sister episode boo gotcha
it's not we have a guest and it's been
never before done
in podcast herstory herstory
from rupaul's drag race
so we'll be right back with our guest
let's talk
hangovers i know sophia what's your
least favorite part about a hangover
other than the fact that i'm
nauseous brain fog can't do anything the
next day
um that's pretty much it well i have a
solution
for you you do yes i do and for all the
unwaxed listeners listen we are so happy
that we found a product that actually
helps you feel better
and stay healthy when you drink this is
called
cbd talks you guys we usually take one
dose before bed it comes in these really
cute
blue and white little tablets and then
the next morning if you
need it which normally we don't because
one will do the trick
and it helps us feel so much better
after drinking
other than that there's no thc so you
actually don't feel the high so don't
worry just because it has cbd
doesn't mean it has thc so you don't
feel all
hallucinogenic or whatever thc does to
your body but
we have a special 20 off discount for
you so go to shop.getcbdtalks.com that's
shop.getcbdtalks that is
cbdtox.com and use the code
unwaxed at checkout they offer a 30-day
money-back guarantee so you have
nothing to lose trying it out again so
go to
shop.getcbdtalks.com and use the code on
wax for 20
off you can also find them on instagram
at cbdoxdetoxremedy
and let us know what you think so
again i'm gonna reiterate the first time
in podcast history this guest has never
appeared
on a podcast before quite literally
ladies and gentlemen we have brought in
a ghost
i was i thought that was funnier in my
head and i really did
it's not that funny but you know it's
good try yes you guys uh we have a ghost
on today but it's not technically we
have a ghost with us i mean we might
maybe
he came with us so she came with us we
we want to talk about
ghost activity because it's been
happening a lot in our house
and we didn't just write this segment as
a joke no no no this has been something
that has been going on for sophie and i
for at least eight years
and it's been happening way more
frequently in our household so that's
why we're bringing it up today because
we were thinking
this is a problem and now we're all
scared hiding under our covers until we
can't
breathe anymore exactly so i don't
really know what i believe in
i don't know if i believe in paranormal
activity ghosts
i'm not really sure yeah but what i do
know is
the noises and the the patterns that
we've been seeing
with these ghosts is is uncanny
yeah you can't say to us at this point
that these
noises and this thing that's been
happening so often cannot be real
uh we i have to say we do believe in
ghosts because cysteine and i were
frequent
watchers of ghost adventures that was
our favorite show growing up
and it still is our favorite show and i
mean i think that some of the things can
be a little fabricated
but what's going on in our house is
definitely real yeah so i'm gonna
describe
the male ghost that lives there and then
i'll let you take over
female ghost yeah so right outside of my
bedroom
there's these old creaky wooden
staircases i'm really gonna set it up
for you guys
and for years i've always told my mom
and my dad
and sophia and scarlett both say they
hear the same thing
these heavy boots boots stomping up the
stairs always around like one in the
morning two in the morning yeah
and then it stopped for a while and then
there was one instance where
at one in the morning i heard it i got
up immediately
checked and i looked down the hall and
scarlet as well
at one in the morning checked as well
and we made eye contact like
holy [ __ ] you heard that too you guys
it's footsteps like
right very distinct my mom makes fun of
me she goes
sistine you're just a sleepwalker and i
go i swear i splashed water on my face
i'm awake and she goes no no no
stop taking that melatonin no i'm gonna
explain
why we think this is actually real
because there's been so many times where
we were home alone
like five years ago and we would be so
scared that there was a burglar in the
house
that we would bring every dog animal
upstairs to guard our doors and our dogs
were
pomeranians at the time so i don't know
what they could have done
all we know from this man ghost well by
the way scarlett
also has locked herself in her closet
before several she was alone
so all we know from this man ghost is
that he has heavy boots
he is probably heavy in weight because
he makes a lot of noise when he's
probably working out because he's going
up and down the stairs
i think he's a fisherman i don't know
why that the first thing that came to my
head i swear
to god i thought it was a fisherman boot
too i've pictured
i pictured this um big old man with like
a
eye patch or something have you ever
ruined that video game we used to play
the scooby-doo video game and it was
like this big sailor man
ghost yep in the game that's the one i
thought of
so of this that is the male ghost living
in this house and he only stays on the
staircase
i haven't seen him or heard him anywhere
since let's talk about the females
okay i'm gonna actually tell this story
from the beginning because i think that
this girl is
relatively kind and new ish yeah we've
been
for about five years for five years yeah
so the first encounter we had with her
was
probably like three years ago and i was
in my bathroom brushing my teeth with
my ex at the time it's the scene was
with her ex um they're watching a movie
in her
i remember i can paint this picture yeah
it's when sausage party the movie
just came out all right what a great
like way to remember a moment in time
how good is that movie about it was at
christmas and then there was that
sausage party
me and my boyfriend so i remember it was
so funny and i remember the volume was
up
extremely bad on my tv and sophia is in
the room our bedrooms are right next
door to each other actually
my closet room my closet room yeah
attaches kind of to your bedroom so
she's in the bathroom brushing her teeth
with her ex yeah i'm watching sausage
party with my by the way
my bathroom is probably the farthest
part of the room from sistine's room so
what happened next
so the sink is on we're brushing our
teeth and i hear
do it again
wait and i turn off the water i
clean out my mouth and i go hey i was
about to say the same
boy
hey bro hey dude
he knows who he is um i was like hey did
you hear that and he's like yeah
is that sistine i go ugh probably she's
probably like in our room laughing and
so and from my perspective i go
we both looked at each other me and my
bro
and i pause the movie and we pause it
and we're both silent we're like
what was because it didn't sound like
sophia's laugh so we we continued to
play it right
so i kind of there's no one in my room i
look at my closet there's no one in my
closet
so me and the boy walk out and i left
you when i say that
and i walk into your room and you're
with your boy ex-boyfriend at the time
and we're like hey positive movie were
you just in our room
and sistine goes no and i go
where i heard you laughing in there and
i said no
you were laughing i don't know you and
it was in the movie that was making me
laugh
because i already saw it and then i said
sistine look at me in the eye
on the count of three we're gonna do the
same laugh we heard
one two three
we freaked out we lost okay but
we knew we knew this was real when
both of the guys heard it too yeah it
was so s my boyfriend
ex boyfriend was so scared that he went
to
church the next day like chaos today
says
we were so scared we begged our exes at
the time
sleep over sleepover they did they left
they dipped we were by ourselves so we
tell this story to my parents and
they're like
you girls are so silly yeah
you don't know what you're thinking what
you're hearing y'all are delusional
so until until recently yeah actually
this week
i would say it's last thursday right
so my mom scarlett and i get home from
dinner
we have these big metal gates that sort
of lock the upstairs area so no one has
gone upstairs yet
we know nobody's home sly's shooting in
atlanta it's nearly impossible to get
yeah
there's no one home
we're baking a snickerdoodle cake
at like 9pm and
my mom hears the door slam actually we
all do here's the door slam
and footprints oh going like that yeah
yeah
and i kid you not the color drained from
her face
we spent the next hour i my first weapon
of choice
a hammer i grabbed a hammer she grabbed
some sort of like
indian mallet that you used to work out
like one of those things
so it was like a wooden indian mallet
and
uh we we go to work we check every inch
of the house
and she goes no no i swear to god i
heard that so now she's
flipping scary she's she's a believer
now thank god
she thought we were delusional for so
long so what we were thinking
is we need to i say these ghosts
overstayed their welcome
i disagree and i think that they should
just stay
because i think you're going to get them
angry what the hell are you on cysteine
can i
so explain what you want to bring and
why i disagree with you because i think
this is
okay i did some research and
technically a person does not need to
die in the home
for a ghost to be there you can bring in
a ghost
through an object like my dad likes to
collect old antique statues or swords or
just really cool stuff
i say a ghost could have gotten brought
in with one of those
right or like a cane like he has a lot
of canes for some reason doesn't use
them but he
has a lot of canes old man with the cane
coming in
old man ghost old man fisher ghost kane
guy he doesn't do anything coming in
sophia he's scary okay but then you're
so you're gonna disrupt them
so basically it was actually my mom's
idea we think that we should
what you're supposed to do to get rid of
a ghost is you bring an expert in
and you sort of say things like ghost
leave no leave or sort of
i don't know if you're supposed to get
an exorcist to sort of get rid of the
ghost or supposed to sage the house
i don't know but we're looking for an
expert in this category
so if you are and you're listening
please send me a dm
and i want to bring you over because i'm
tired of this
all right and i'm going to give you my
um the advice you need
and the advice we should stick with
because when we bring this thing in the
house
this person to get rid of the ghosts and
disrupt the whole energy
let me just note this yes we hear
footsteps yes we hear women laughing and
chattering
whatever it's not a negative
energy i still fall asleep at night i
don't feel like someone's pulling off my
sheets
yes the footsteps have freaked us out
before but now we're all aware of it
and we all know it's there no he's kind
of like looking for the [ __ ] this is the
thing
i think this is what's going to happen
this person is going to come in and go
go away now these ghosts are pissed
and then they are gonna start haunting
us and then they're like oh you're gonna
kick us out of our house
they live there too by the way we are
gonna not be able to sleep
now i'm thinking from the perspective of
a podcaster here
perhaps if we did disrupt these ghosts
that would make for some good content
i'm just saying
i would rather fall asleep at night
because then i'm going to be
abroad on this episode or the next few
episodes without sleep
we could use a little bratty sophia she
can come out occasionally but
that's i think that's our take on yeah i
think that's our take we'll we'll move
on and
oh so sophia and i for a long time since
we first started on wax we
wanted right off the bat to do a
conspiracy theory segment
and we actually never i don't know why
it took us so long we never got around
well you know what it was
we never had the time we always had
guests on and we thought
how do we how would we do a whole intro
about conspiracy like random like hey
guys can seriously theory now we have
someone to talk about
mental health like it just wouldn't make
sense it doesn't flow so what we thought
for this episode
and maybe future episodes if you enjoy
hearing these is
you can give us some yeah give us some
but sophie and i are each going to
bring in one conspiracy knowing that the
other person isn't aware of it already
and then share so today sophia brought
in a conspiracy she's going to share
with me and it just a disclaimer
we're doing this for fun we don't
actually like we're choosing theories
that are almost too absurd to be real
but let us just pretend and have
but this conspiracy theory ladies and
gentlemen
is so believed by people that i had to
bring it in because i didn't even
believe that at least four percent of
voters
in 2013 12 million people in the us
believe that this conspiracy theory
right
take it away okay
this is the conspiracy theory about
lizard people lizard people
do you know the conspiracy theory i've
heard about it yes okay
it's like this so yeah you may or may
not know jones talks a lot about
people oh does he oh yeah he does all
the time oh
he's definitely someone that would
believe in this so lizard people if you
don't know what they are
they are cold-blooded humanoid
reptilians who have the power
to shift into human form so the guy
this guy named david ike who's the
theorist and like lizard people said
that these creatures have claws in their
human kind
had their claws into humankind since
ancient time and they believe that world
leaders like queen elizabeth
um george bush the clintons bob hope
are all lizard people wait say those
names again
they think that lizard people are queen
elizabeth
george bush the clintons and bob hope
etc
are the lizard people they believe it's
people that are prominent figures within
politics or did bob ike come in
with these no this is david david he
believes that those people
are they've shifted into human form to
take over the world
that's awesome so these shape-shifting
reptilians
are aliens controlled control earth by
taking on human form
and gaining political power to
manipulate human societies
and lizard people want one thing what
world domination no
wait yeah so that's why they take over
okay have you ever seen those videos on
youtube where people
have blinked and their eyes turned into
a world well the only one
was when justin bieber was on trial
peeing in a bucket or something and his
eyes changed that's
that's that's what they thought were
lizards they think that justin bieber
might be a lizard person
okay so i'm gonna just tell you really
quick if you guys are now freaked out
and you're like
how how do i know if someone's a lizard
person i'll tell you
these are the traits of a lizard person
that they're green eyes
that change to blue they have good
eyesight and hearing so i'm already off
that list
i have horrible eyesight and i i have
selective hearing
sistine knows that yeah um they have
sometimes
red true hair color which is not always
i mean whatever
um they have a sense of not belonging to
the human race
they have unexplained scars on their
body they love space
just love space sounding a lot like my
ex
low blood pressure i dated a lizard
that's the caption almost done ufo
contacts like esb
and their capabilities to disrupt
electoral
appliances like i think that they can
turn on an oven from a distance or like
the microwave starts going off that's
right awesome
so we could be walking around them and
just not even know it
so that's your conspiracy that well yeah
lizard people exist i'll tell you why
because i thought this is insane that
at least 12 million people in the u.s
believe this
that's a lot so how many people
are lizard people i don't it's like one
and how many
i think it's more they say the prominent
figures within our society today so it's
people that
are the rulers so they've they've
believed example
oh my god exhibit a they believe donald
trump
if anyone's just listening to this
you guys need to watch this on youtube
if you're not seeing this i have a photo
um i've done on donald trump like moving
into a lizard but by the way
they also think that obama is a lizard
person okay
so at this point and that takes us to
our our game if you are a
we're playing a game lizard or a human
and you're going to put up the sign so
this is a human
this is the best game ever so i gave
sistine two figures just a human face
and a lizard face and
i wrote down a list of seven people and
some of them are people that they
considered lizard humans
and then some are not so you're gonna
guess which ones are
and which ones are not let's do it
britney spears
oh foley lizard what do you mean ding
ding ding she likes
shaped what 2000's is today yes ready
madonna lizard what yeah right how
how again another just because you know
what you're listing people that have
changed the music industry not only for
women but for
the world yeah you know who i thought
was a lizard person i thought bellathorn
was a lizard person
maybe we bring her on and ask we can ask
her um danny devito
not here man he's a man yeah i love
danny devito i know danny davis he's a
man
obama i kind of listen they consider him
a lizard person
jennifer aniston
i'm gonna have to go with person yeah
jennifer anderson is not a lizard person
apparently
um mark zuckerberg lizard yeah
they think he's a lizard person by the
way you guys i'm not saying they are
this is what
people have said just credit users yeah
reddit users
and last but not least paul rudd
i'm gonna go lizard
they haven't taken him over he's a
little it's a human
i was trying to go ballsy with that one
ah knew it
do you think dad's a lizard oh
it makes sense oh he kind of has the
skin texture
[Music]
i don't know you know mom looks more
like a lizard he has the same size hands
as this lizard
he doesn't have a long of a tongue
though no because his toes
the nose is the same does that mean you
guys are lizards
oh [ __ ] are we a half lizard is my eyes
turning
gently are my eyes changing he walks
like this too
he does walk when he's hungry yeah so he
does transfer into that mom does look
like sophia that was
an epic game thank you so much i'm gonna
keep these
okay so check out lizard people if you
don't believe me okay that was such a
good conspiracy
next time i will bring in a good one for
you um
so we thought we would wrap up the show
today with doing an
unsolicited advice segment again another
segment we wanted to do with the show
and just haven't gotten around to it so
we asked
the followers on our unwaxed instagram
go follow if you haven't
just any questions that they have for us
any advice that they want answered
again we'll probably give you the wrong
advice
but bad advice is better than no advice
so let's get into it okay so our first
question we're gonna keep these
anonymous but if you guys would like
your
usernames included we will be happy to
do that just include that with a message
this girl wrote okay hi first of all i'm
obsessed with you guys
and your podcast thank you i'm 21 years
old and i feel like
so many people around me are getting
into relationships except me
it doesn't really bother me and honestly
i thrive being single
me amen but it starts to bother me a
little sometimes because i'm super
outgoing
and meet a lot of people but no one i
feel i click with
also me yes it can start to get to me
because i feel like everyone has an
easier time
getting into relationships i've never
been in a full relationship but i've
gone out with lots of guys before and
had little flings
i was just always really focused on
school and just living my life on my own
with my friends good for you girl
do you guys have any advice can i start
off by saying
i have never related to a question yeah
that was perfectly written
honestly this could not have been better
written for anybody
but us because i know for me i
have definitely been feeling the same
way like i think cysteine and i we are
good on our own we have been we have
been i know we make fun of like oh
sophie has been going on a lot of dates
but she's gone on some dates too
but nothing seems to be clicking with
this time we've been single i completely
agree with you i feel like
all of my friends are in long-term
relationships like my best friend has
been dating a guy for nearly five years
now
and i'm always the single one in the
group and
it's hard because that's the environment
and that's the people that you're
constantly
surrounded with so if you were
surrounded with uh single
individuals you wouldn't feel so bad
about being single and i i know for my
whole friend group
every single one of my girlfriends is in
a three plus year relationship and
they're considering moving in together
and they're going to get married yeah
that's not something
i mean really needing right now but i
just i'm a big believer in that
everything happens for a reason
and time will will tell the truth and so
right now it's just not your time it's
not my time it's not even
sophia's time because at one point we
were in long-term relationships together
and now we're both single long-term so i
think that
just keep doing you i love that you're
focusing on school and your friendships
and
don't let it bother you because i think
also right now it's you know we're in
quarantine we're stuck inside
we're not distracted our minds aren't as
stimulated as they once were so
you're thinking a lot about being alone
but also being alone is okay
because during this time focus on you
better yourself
and then a relationship will come
because you're just
thriving at life and you sound like you
already have a really good mindset
going into this so just keep at that and
what sistine just said
the right guy will come at the right
time some people just get into
relationships
way easier than others yeah but that
also comes with some things being forced
and there's some things that don't end
up working out in the long run
so just keep doing you and the right
person will just be thrust upon you and
i also want to add
being 21 because i'm 22 dating
boys that are 21 and yes i'm calling
them boys because
they act like boys so it is hard to find
someone
your age that has the maturity that
maybe you want
it really depends what you're looking
it's hard to find a really mature guy
that wants a serious relationship
so hang in there girl good luck let me
know
keep us updated if you find someone
and number two is any health trends
you're on
i'll let you take this away i can just
take this on and we can make this short
and sweet but
overall i would like to disclaim that
cysteine and i are
relatively i think are very healthy
people we do work out consistently we do
make sure that our food is whole healthy
organic
we don't cook a lot we feel like we try
to but we'll just end up putting like
our cooking is oatmeal and smoothies
yeah literally it's all beyond smoothies
um
but overall we do have our
off weeks like there are days where we
are weeks where we won't work out
we'll just keep eating like we'll have
ice cream for dinner every single night
yeah
and i think that's what the whole
important part of doing like the 80 20
thing is like never restrict yourself
from things you don't want to
like i definitely we make cookies like
every single day and i'll have a cookie
probably every single day
but i this is kind of funny that you
bring this up because i just decided to
do this whole other kind of health kick
and trends that i've never really done
before
so i've been drinking chlor i almost
like i almost said chloroform i'm not
drinking chloroform
don't drink i said that again i'm
drinking chlorophyll
and do you know what chlorophyll is i
don't okay i didn't know what it was
either but
when i read about i was like oh this is
great it's really detoxing for your body
and it's supposed to i don't have this
problem but
it helps your natural odors like your
breath is supposed to smell better
you're not supposed to have as much bo
it just kind of detoxes your body so it
says
that yeah so antioxidant properties
detoxifies your body
it's a power plant powered source of
energy and more oxygen
which sounds pretty cool that sounds
cool which sounds great i think sophia
and i what we like to do is we like to
try a bunch of different experiments
with
dieting and we don't actually like to
diet but we do like to
so for example like we're very health
conscious so if we're making
a banana bread like one week we'll make
a banana bread with the four cups of
sugar as
intended and then another week i'll find
a recipe on like
buzzfeed tasting pinterest yeah on
pinterest and we'll find like a healthy
substitute so again it's we love to
balance and
um we we're really into like walking at
least 30 minutes a day that is so good
for your body to get moving especially
after a big meal
especially if you're also anxious that
helps you that i think health also goes
along with like body and mentally and
this is another thing that i've been
taking
i don't really know how to pronounce it
correctly and it's been kind of helping
because i
i do have i get anxious occasionally and
it's called ashwagandha
do you have ashwagandha yes yes it's
bingo
so i take three capsules a day and it's
supposed to relieve stress and anxiety
it's supposed to increase
energy and stamina regulate your blood
sugar improve brain function and memory
sophia sophia takes all the cool fancy
stuff
and then she'll report back to me and it
actually has made me feel i mean maybe i
don't know if it's mental maybe it is
mental
but it has helped a bit like i feel like
i've been a little bit more easy going
when i
when i didn't have it yesterday and i
was a bit of a pain yesterday so
there we go you never know ashwagandha
yeah but those i i like to do all like
the fun like supplement trends and then
sistine likes to hear what i'm doing and
then she'll
pick it up i think for us our number one
takeaway from this
question is that everything in
moderation life's a balance some days i
wake up
super bloated and you feel gross and
other days you wake up and you feel
really good
so just as long as whatever your body
feels
the best at do don't ever follow someone
else because
you are not built the same and if you
guys do want to know
specifically what we eat in the day how
we do our workout routines let us know
because we are
deep we can deep dive into it okay so
that i think would uh
conclude we did our first sister episode
congratulations sisters
oh yeah oh i thought she's a lizard
thanks guys i hope you can join us next
week let us know how we did please
rate and review our episodes on apple
podcast because we
truly appreciate it and we love hearing
from you guys and we will see you
next week bye from all of us here at the
show
thanks for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts
at sophia stallone and at sistine
stallone and be sure to follow the show
at unwaxed podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week